make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and a
couple of things before we start this
video
um for those of you guys who are on the
discord server and you'll find a link to
the discord down in the description
uh we have some cool stuff coming for
you guys right so we've got like a
riddler bot
where like a the riddler will like
escape from arkham asylum and will show
up at different places throughout the
server and
if you guessed this riddle correctly
then one of the winners will be picked
for something like a t-shirt
maybe a rob core ring or something like
that we're still getting the rewards
rewards fleshed out
but that'll be coming relatively soon
and then we're also kicking around the
idea of a dungeons and dragons or
superhero themed
dungeons and dragons right dmd kind of
tournament thing which seems like it'd
be really cool a lot of you guys been
asking for it for a while so
uh make sure you guys check out the
discord server down in the description i
think it'd be pretty awesome
but um but what i want to talk about in
this video is i want to talk about
thor force specifically like gore the
god butcher
and like jane foster thor and then odin
sun thor
and and one of the funny things there's
actually a theory floating around out
there
now i'm not the one who came up with
this theory but this is not my theory
i want to get that kind of cleared right
off the bat so people are just like i
heard that from rob he's the one that
made it up
that's not true i actually saw this
theory kind of circulating around the
internet and a fan actually gave it to
me
on twitter but it's it's a it's a cool
little cool little tidbit here right so
one of the questions people have asked
is that if in thor 4
we're going to have chris hemsworth thor
and then we're also going to have like
natalie portman's jane foster thor
uh are they both gonna be running around
at the same time are we gonna have like
two thor's in those in that movie and i
think the answer to that question is no
we're not gonna have two thor's
i think we're gonna have three uh this
is gonna be the crazy thing about it
right so like three thor's
and thor four i think it's gonna be kind
of kind of bonkers uh so here's the deal
the story is based on gore the god
butcher or at least he's going to be the
villain now as always with the marvel
cinematic universe
never expect a direct adaptation of a
comic right which is to say
basically the comic book being filmed
shot for shot and then given given to us
in the as
the movie going audience that never
happens right it's usually just
the general idea of the story and then
reworked for movie form which usually
makes sense
because for the most part you can't
really get away with the kind of things
in movies that you can get away with
comics because
you're working with real life actors you
have a screenplay you got to make sure
it stays
under a certain amount of time there's a
lot of variables that go into making a
film
uh but in the the original god butcher
story what you basically had there at
least towards the end
was three generations of thor all facing
off against gore now in the comic it was
thor from three different timelines
right so thor when he was younger
thor in the modern era and thor in the
future um in the movie i think it's
gonna be a little bit different
right i think we're gonna get jane
foster thor in the future because
somewhere along the line between now
and then odin's son either loses the
ability to lift his hammer
or he passes it on to jane foster
because like odin odin like somebody's
gotta run asgard
and so you know thor's basically like
i'm gonna be the one to run the show
here
jane foster you keep an eye on earth and
then he basically passes the mantle off
to her
um it could be that he loses the ability
to wield his hammer right he's no longer
worthy of it which is what happened in
the comics right he lost his worthiness
and was just kind of there right like he
loses stormbreaker or whatever the case
is
maybe mjolnir comes back and he's not
worthy of wielding it but whatever
happens to be the case
jane foster will be the one to take up
the mantle so i wouldn't be surprised if
you see natalie portman
as thor but she's older right she's
maybe like 20 years older 30 years older
something like that
and then that kind of leaves the
question what's the younger version of
thor that we're gonna see
and this is when things get interesting
i think we're gonna see beta ray bill
and a lot of people ask that but a lot
of people are like you know who would
the younger thor be in this situation
and i think it would be beta ray bill i
think we might end up getting him now
the question is how and why and that's
the answer i don't really have like i
don't have the answer to the question
how would we get beta ray bill or why
would we get beta ray bill because the
only thing we've seen about his
character
is he is one of the champions on sakhar
right and thor three he was one of the
former champions who was defeated at
some point along
some point on the line and we never
really found out when right i think it'd
be cool to find out that he was defeated
by the incredible hulk
right when when hulk first showed up on
sakhar he defeated beta ray bill and
became the new champion that would be
awesome
right but um but there's there's there's
nothing to really indicate
that like beta ray bill does in any form
or fashion have any dealings
with any of the superheroes or any of
the earth based characters or anything
and comics it would make a lot more
sense because when when vader ray bill
first showed up when walt simonson was
writing thor
that beta ray bill was kind of an
accidental discovery right the beta ray
bill was kind of like this
cyborg based protector of his people who
were leaving their planet because it was
destroyed by surter
and uh this led to thor basically
intervening at the request of nick fury
to find out what this great big huge
caravan of space-faring vehicles was
doing
and it led to a fight between thor and
beta rayville and then ultimately a kind
of tournament of sorts right but you
know there was kind of instituted by
odin
to determine who could wield mjolnir and
uh when when beta ray bill initially
defeated thor
and picked up his hammer that's what led
to the whole tournament and ultimately
odin you know
vader ray bill i think lost and odin
ended up giving him his own hammer
called a stormbreaker right that's the
original stormbreaker hammer
and marvel comics uh things that you
guys can tell have changed a lot in the
mcu in comparison to the comics
so because of that there's there's
really no telling how this could work
um i think it'd be cool if we got beta
ray bill but i think that most likely
what you'll see is just a younger
version of odin's son but i think that
makes the most sense right a younger
version of
of thor uh who in his younger days was
brash headstrong
wouldn't really listen to reason and i
think it'd be a great compliment to you
know in all honesty to kind of
have this younger version of thor who's
trying to be tamed by his modern age
self
and to kind of see how far his how much
his character has changed
you know since the time before he was
banished from asgard onto earth
and like how much he's learned since
he's been on earth fighting alongside
humans you know
during the events of infinity war
avengers in-game that kind of a thing um
so there's there's a lot of really cool
storytelling that could be done there
but for the long and short of this
in terms of how jane foster fits in i
think that's what we're going to get
the real question to ask here is are we
going to get that future version of loki
that killed the world
right because those you guys who don't
know in in the in that story right
angora the god butcher
there's a point where it kind of ties
into that story but not directly it was
actually during the events
of journey into mystery i think the the
comics that were being published at the
time
but there's one point where future loki
actually kills everything on earth like
all the superheroes all the super
villains all of humanity
he literally wipes out the world right
it's just this dead empty husk
and uh thor is just kind of sitting in
asgard with all the asgardians being
dead
and he's just kind of the king of
nothing right and then eventually
galactus shows up on earth trying to
consume it and it leads to a great big
fight between like old king
thor and galactus which is super cool i
doubt we'll see galactus in that
but um but you know it's suffice it to
say in in this whole thing i haven't
said that for us in a while
suffice it to say suffice it to say in
in the midst of all this
thor 4 i think is going to be a really
really fun and entertaining film
uh gor the god butcher is an amazing
villain he's captivating he's riveting
uh he's wildly fascinating i would say
he's probably the most
interesting thor villain that was ever
created in marvel comics uh so hats off
to
to jason aaron for the invention of that
character but
uh at this point you know it's really
too early to tell but it's really too
early to know
exactly what the plot is going to be uh
but you know as we get closer to the
release of the film
we'll see like bits of news dropping and
and some spoiler leaks and
and different things like that and we'll
get a better indication of what the
movie is going to look like but
i wouldn't be surprised if the jane
foster character in the thor 4 film
is just a future version of thor who
wields the hammer after for whatever
reason
odin's son ends up losing it ends up
losing the ability to do so whether he
chooses to give it up
or he has to because he loses the
ability to be worthy because we have to
believe that mjolnir is going to come
back at some point right
it'll be remade it'll be reformed
something along those lines it's not
going to be gone forever
right it's thor's signature weapon you
know it's the one thing he's best known
for
is like the square looking hammer that
he just beats people up with
right so um either way i think it's
going to be awesome i'm very very
excited for it
but i want to know you all's thoughts
right i want to hear your all's thoughts
so post them down in the comments
section
what do you think of this theory right
do you think it's a good one do you
think it's a bad one
can you think of one better i'm really
excited to see what kind of responses
you guys have
so uh with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rod poor if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
oh you said peace
i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
game
bye